every Thursday we highlight stories
affecting consumers over the past year
Americans reportedly borrowed an
estimated eighty eight billion dollars
to pay medical bills unbelievable we've
partnered with kaiser Health News and
NPR on their bill of the month series
which uncovers shocking medical bills
the latest looks at the cost of a
life-saving dialysis treatment for 50
year-old soverign Valentine he calls
himself solved for short solve and his
wife Jessica say their insurance company
allegiance said there were no in network
dialysis clinics in Montana the company
though disputes is based on their
records soverign used an out-of-network
facility and received a bill for more
than five hundred and forty thousand
dollars for 14 weeks of care the doctor
that I saw said you will do dialysis or
you will die our balance bill now is up
to more than five hundred thousand
dollars to me that's clearly just so
wrong it seems unethical it was shocking
it was overwhelming you know it can be
distressing to get bills but it was so
high that it was like how could this
possibly be well in a statement the
insurance company Allegiant said quote
the main issue here seems to be a
misunderstanding about the availability
and location of in-network dialysis
centers in Montana allegiance later also
made special arrangements for an
in-network option in Missoula the
insurance company paid more than sixteen
thousand dollars but the couple still
owes the unpaid balance of more than
five hundred and twenty thousand dollars
the editor-in-chief of kaiser Health
News Elizabeth Rosenthal joins us now
good to see you what I kept thinking
about when I read this this could happen
to anybody
so what should the Valentines have done
differently because this could happen to
somebody else
well jessica is a trained physician and
she worked the system as she was
supposed to so this is kind of a case of
the insurer and the provider not being
able to agree on whose fault it is and
it's hostage-taking of poor soft
Valentine right who who's left with this
bill you can as she did you look to find
a provider in network always that's a
first step and it's really smart she
to the directory which was hugely you
know as we know many directories are
inaccurate they're confusing it's hard
to find your loved one is sick and there
was apparently no one in network she
checked with a representative from the
insurer to confirm that and then she
even went to the Insurance Commissioner
to say hey I I looked and there's no one
in network so she did a whole lot of
stuff in the setting of a very serious
life crisis for her husband and you know
when we fall into one of those kind of
loopholes or pitfalls boy the cost can
be half a million dollars and and and no
one seems to kind of feel the human
reaction of hey you know she tried
really hard but and so we're gonna
settle this the insurer and the provider
are working now to settle it but they're
still in the thick of a big disagreement
and as you said you know she's been
offered well maybe we'll cut the bill by
half well great that's still two hundred
you know right that doesn't seem to work
so well I mean as you said they're
working on we have a comment from the
the kidney dialysis center which is
Fresenius they said they're working
directly as you said with the patient to
immediately resolve this situation so
what should their nips next up being
ultimately will they have to pay this
bill I really hope they won't you know
they hopefully for seen us and
especially now that there's been press
coverage and we see this over and over
again once there's press coverage hey
the bill disappears but of course that's
not a solution for everyone who
Elizabeth how does a bill get that high
that's that's what I find so much well
it's pretty shocking you know what we
see is Medicare pays for most kidney
dialysis you know this country they pay
about two hundred and thirty five
dollars a session the saath saath was
charged fourteen thousand dollars a
session so the list price is you know
fifty times higher than the price that
Medicare would pay most private insurers
will negotiate that down to about four
or five times what Medicare would pay
what does a fair price the sky's the
limit the the price of a procedure is
whatever the market will bear
if you're stuck it will bear a lot I
think one option for for anyone who's
stuck in this dilemma is to find out
what Medicare would pay say okay we'll
pay two or three times that and we'll
work that out that that seems fair to
all involved but you know actor
thank you I hope they do work it out